the Joe Rogan experience so you see what
the kids making now oh yeah they make a
real money oh my gosh
millions million millions playing video
game please no leg kicks did you see
yeah did you see did you see what's his
name
Sean almighty gave like he came 15 plays
and he made like more whatever it is and
they did a comparison of how much he
made like twenty seven thousand twenty
seven five hundred thousand and ever
since fights
yeah there's his face they did it they
compared it to his fights I was like
what that's crazy
he could be a professional fortnight for
a nighter he's good too I saw a couple
his dreams
wow that's well he had to do something
right he didn't he get [ __ ] over by a
band supplement yeah Sean O'Malley says
he makes around 4500 hours a month or
gaming he just want 20 was 27,500 gave
it to he gave it all to a charity really
he came fourteen place or eight play
something like that but he also chair
he's the man I like that yeah yeah and
then I think so I think that he got
caught what was was with I think was
marijuana or something like what it was
it's not what it was I thought it was a
tainted supplement oh yeah I think it's
Jamie was saying that they're gonna not
test baseball players anymore for pot I
saw that yeah good good that's what we
want a bunch of stolen people out there
trying to catch a ball every terrible
maybe better they know where that ball
is going
they took marijuana off their list but
they added opioids which is oh that's
good thing but yes that it was so oh boy
it's weren't on the list before people
are like horn what what that's that's
crazy cuz that's a real problem man
that's so that's a real problem
opioids is the real problem not
marijuana that's great that's hey no
Hawaii has a lot of drug issues well
100% yeah yeah one understand how do you
avoid that chick growing up huh you know
like I saw it I saw like I remember like
being like dingo 8008 no night how we
had to be younger maybe I was six seven
six or seven my brother's young one
younger than me I remember like my uncle
coming into the bathroom and my mom was
showering me and my brother and like
just fighting with my mom like this that
they're fighting like fist fighting and
like you know like this is normal or you
know like Isis like Isis like crazy in
Hawaii and this is Beth yeah meth and I
was like holy [ __ ] this is nuts and then
I see like my friends and family their
parents or whatever or even going to
high school they're my friends doing it
this and that I'm like guys it's not for
me like I ain't gonna do this [ __ ] like
I I see what it did to my family how
affect and someone might look like
people I love his friends and stuff
families and I was like I ain't gonna do
this and then and then that's just why I
just stayed away I never I never did
anything I never did no type of joke not
even marijuana never tried it really
never never did not die ya know that's
what's funny
I don't need it yeah I just I just saw I
just saw what a lot of people think and
then I step away from marijuana for the
wrong reasons because when using high
school you remember when I heard this
always sticks out to me whenever you
talk about it is when you bring up the
dog no you're not that's a bit from my
life I think that's from 2009 and I
really wish you wouldn't smoke it
doesn't I was graduating so that's when
I was in there
play that [ __ ] let me hear go back read
rewind a little bit so I can hear the
whole thing
I wish you didn't smoke weed you're not
the same when you smoke and I miss my
friend I'll be outside
what the [ __ ] would they think of you
that commercial you are nothing
I really think you're not very wise our
cocaine and sleeping pills her [ __ ]
dog is talking to her not only that
she's not even reacting if your dog was
talking to you when you were high you'd
be like [ __ ] you could talk wait wait
this old dive you use the Deaf bath of
outside what are you doing why are you
barking at me if you want food double
you wanna eat yeah it's just so good she
doesn't even react she's like she's not
freaking at a hat she's not freak you
would freak the [ __ ] out yeah Marshall
started talking to me a bit like what
hold on do that again get my phone out
yeah that was a stupid commercial no
yeah
[Applause]